我记得有一段话讲的特别的有意思，就是请赐予我勇气，让我去改变那些可以改变的，请赐予我宽容，让我去接纳那些我不能改变的。最后，请赐予我智慧，让我去分辨他们两者之间的差别，哪些是可以改变的，哪些是不能改变的。如果我的老公他就是一个比较自我的，不会主动做家务的，不会主动关心人的这样一个男人，我接纳他的不同，讲实话，也没有很大的事情，就是想和你聊一聊天，想你骂骂我想你说说我，让我清醒一下。其实，我平常也是很清醒很理智的一个人，我也想的很开。主要是想咨询一下感情的问题，就是我跟我的老公在一起已经15年了，就是感情的问题，我有点疑惑，有点迷茫，因为也想自己过得比较好嘛，因为我比较喜欢听你说话，就让你点醒我一下，我以后该怎么的去做。是这样子的，我和我的老公呢，已经在一起15年，结婚已经十二三年了嘛。感情的话，我自己觉得还可以，但是的话呢，我就感觉到生活当中我感受不到他的爱，我不知道该怎么办，因为我的话，是比较一个乐观积极向上，对孩子啊，对老公啊，对家庭都很用心也很上心的一个人。但是就觉得老公他比较沉默啊，话少啊啥的，就觉得我感受不到他。
他对我的爱有时候在想，女人嘛，就是三样价值，情绪价值、劳动价值、经济价值。但是我有经济价值，他这一点是钱全部都在我手上，但是我就感受不到他的爱，就是我都不知道要怎么去做这个事情。因为我也想让孩子看到家庭和睦啊，父母恩爱啊，这样的话，老公呢，他就是交钱很主动，别的任何事情他都不主动了，然后我就不知道我该怎么的。因为女人嘛，确实是希望对孩子好嘛。家里父母笑脸相迎啊，相谈甚欢啊，这样子的话，主要是对孩子对下一代比较好嘛。因为让孩子感受到爱的话，对于孩子的成长会比较好嘛。因为我是一个妈妈嘛，是不是我也知道我自己要求的多，可能别人都说我矫情，但是因为女人毕竟结婚过日子嘛，肯定都想要的多一点嘛，所以就想能不能可以点醒我一下。其实我也很清醒，不爱就不爱嘛，只要关系好，我们又不吵架又有钱，他又不出去吃喝，下班就回家，然后就干他的工作。工作干完了，他就玩一下手机，就是这种，但是对于生活中的细节，家里任何事情，家务他不做也不帮忙，除非我主动开口，哎，老公帮我做一下，他就会做。撒个娇啊，什么他会做，但是撒娇撒了十多年，我好累呀，可能大家都觉得我要的多，是不是每个人啊，他对于两个人。
人之间相处的那个亲密关系的亲密度要求是不一样的，我认为我们女性如果自己对这个亲密度要求高并不是一件可耻的事情，也不用害怕别人会怎么看待我这件事情。我直播间也有很多姐妹，可能在我们的世界里面，我们对这个亲密度要求没有那么高。可能老公他只要把工资交给我了，只要能让我好好的，没有后顾之忧的，没有经济上的压力的，能把这一日三餐三餐四季安排好，能把孩子的事情都安排好，我就谢天谢地了。我理解直播间的很多女性的这个想法，但是我想说的，如果我们女人对两性关系的亲密关系度要求比较高，这件事情也是合理的，它不是可耻的，它不是能够拿来被大家贬低和踩，就是我就会觉得很郁闷。比如说，有时候我在洗澡，因为我两个孩子都比较黏我的娃娃仔，就会说妈妈，妈妈妈妈使劲叫我使劲敲门，但是爸爸就在旁边，妈妈都不会走过来说，诶，你找妈妈干什么呀，或者是爸爸可以干什么什么。他说从来没有过，如果是这种情况的话，我说这个，我怕被网暴，80%的男的都差不多80%吧，我也不敢说多了，我怕我被网暴，我对老公其实没有要求，真的，他工作比较忙嘛，我什么都是把他放在第一位，我就比如家里，我想我。
给自己上班讲实话，我事业单位的我娘都是那个的收入的话，我确实没有她高。她一年有80~100个，我的话才10多个。我就把我定位成一个家庭主妇吧，把我孩子带好啊，回家就是家里搞得干干净净啊，整整齐洁。因为他喜欢比较干净整洁的环境了他喜欢吃什么水果，每天都给他做好弄好啊。然后，我一般不跟他红脸，也不说他也不凶，他都是很好吃的。哎，老公怎么的，他就是嗯还好，嗯，好。比如说前两天父亲节，我就喊孩子画了一幅图给他老师说诶，今天父亲节，我们祝爸爸节日快乐，我们给爸爸画个画吧。孩子就画了画，很开心很激动的找到爸爸面前，爸爸今天你过节，我给你发了什么什么，他来句嗯，好，没有就是生活中就很多事情就是这样子的。有时候我觉得别人也说了，你老公钱都给你了，你还想要啥？其实我啥也不想要，他也可以不爱我。但是这个东西我不知道怎么讲，我就想农村律师帮帮我，是不是我要求太多了？不是说我来骂你的问题，我是希望你能够抽离出来，去看清人和人的不同，接纳人和人的不同，可能对于你的丈夫来说，他把钱都交给你了，这就是他的爱。对于你的丈夫来说，他可能本人并不是那种仪式感、亲密度要求很高的人，你理解吗？他无论是对谁都是很冷淡，因为他是专业于搞科研的。
他学历很高，就已经是中国比较高的学历了。是这种，他就专注于做自己的事情。其实，我也知道他工作真的很辛苦很累。我就是尽量的哎呀，我老公上班那么辛苦，我应该多体谅他。但是，有一点呢，他就除了把钱交给我了，他就是觉得婚姻很好，他就要结婚。他要有我这样的老婆。然后，我有时候跟他讲，就是说，可不可以对我也笑脸相迎一点？有时候也担心他在单位上混不下去嘛。讲实话，单位上他因为人比较厉害了，话比较少，我就觉得他情商太low了。我跟你讲啊，姐妹啊，这个世界这个宇宙有很多东西，它是非常玄妙的一种平衡。我换句话说，如果你老公是那种会讨女生欢心的，会笑脸相迎的，会跟女人各种缠绵的，你觉得你老公第一这些年会一直这么稳定的在这个家庭里面待着吗？第二，你老公选的一定会是你吗？就正因为他是那种冷淡的、木讷的，不太会讨好女人的，不懂得跟女人调情的，所以他才打你手上了呢。也是就是，所以我就想你妈妈，我就就是怎么平衡自己，因为我毕竟又上班又有两个娃，还要做所有的家务，那我怎么平衡好不好？第一，承认人和人的不同，我们就是不同的人。但是我们有这样的缘分，我们组成了家庭，我们有了小孩，我们用。
各自的模式去生活，只要没有造成重大的冲突，我们可以在各自的轨道上一直往前走下去，保持各自的风格。如果他不是很喜欢仪式感，不是很喜欢那个亲密度的话，那你就不要寄希望于说他看到孩子给他写了一个父亲节快乐的纸片，会有什么啊，就欢欣雀跃的那样的表现，就是接纳人与人之间的不同，再有一个是什么？学会花钱解决问题，我就是不会花钱。你这玩意儿得学啊，如果你不会花钱解决问题的话，这是你的课题。如果你老公一年能挣80万，100万，你自己也能挣几万块钱的话，你老公不在家的时候，请钟点工回来打扫卫生回来干家里面的家务活，干一干。你要学会花钱解决问题。如果你学不会，这是你的课题，人家100万80万的工资都交到你手上了，如果你还不能把自己过得开开心心的，还不能把自己从家务当中繁琐的这些事当中解放出来的话，那就是你的不对。还有一点，我们家的大孩子，他是个自闭症的孩子，也要多花钱解决问题，你要学一些比如跟保险金、信托相关的关系大的孩子，如果以后他自己无法自理。
自己无法去保护自己的话，你们将来要用法律、用制度、用这些金融工具来保障他以后的生活无虞、生活无忧，保证有人能够在财产上保证他以后不至于到时候你们不在了。你说全靠弟弟或者全靠妹妹的话也不行的，不要给弟弟妹妹增加经济上的麻烦。第一，接纳人和人的不同，我没有办法改变他，我记得有一段话讲的特别的有意思，就是请赐予我勇气，让我去改变那些可以改变的，请赐予我宽容，让我去接纳那些我不能改变的。最后，请赐予我智慧，让我去分辨他们两者之间的差别，哪些是可以改变的，哪些是不能改变的。如果我的老公他就是一个比较自我的，不会主动做家务的，不会主动关心人的这样一个男人，我接纳他的不同。然后，我这一头的话，我一定要学会花钱来减轻我的身体上的劳作，让我有更多的时间来爱护自己，更多的时间为孩子的将来去做打算去做考量。讲实话，我对于什么旅游啊，出去玩啊，朋友聚会啊，这些我都通通都不感兴趣，我就只想把时间花在孩子身上，还有一个事儿，我觉得你可以去做一做，你去学一下非暴力。
沟通语言逻辑，你可以听一下樊登老师讲的非暴力沟通，或者听一下别的老师讲的非暴力沟通。你也可以买樊登老师的那个翻书APP的会员，多听一下樊登老师讲的婚姻家庭关系、夫妻关系的一些书。非暴力沟通。他其实逻辑是这样的，就是跟一个人沟通的时候，是先讲事实，讲我的感受。比如说，举个例子，你老公有一次带着你去他的同事啊朋友那聚餐的时候，给你开了车门或者给你夹了菜。你一定要正向的反馈给他。我说老公，你今天带我在你的同事面前，你给我夹菜，我觉得好幸福啊，我觉得好哦，我都有做这件事情，因为我的大孩子是自闭症儿童，我学了很多关于和这种自闭症孩子沟通啊，交流就是强化嘛，强化他的某个行为，表扬啊，夸奖啊，什么就是我在生活当中也是这么运用的。我就说可能是老公太忙太辛苦了，就不想说话或什么的。所以我就想你妈妈，我是不是太不知足了？不要这么想问题，不要上来就觉得是自己的问题，自己的错。客观的来看待，我们是不同的性格，我们对于亲密度的要求是不一样的，因为如果今天我把你骂回去了，那在你心里永远是一个压抑你的过程。你有这个需要，他没有这个需要，我不能阉割了你的需求就承认不同。我跟你说，年纪越大。
越能接纳这个世界的不同，越能接纳人和人的不同，越能说在我的这条轨道上，只要我身体健康，只要孩子身体健康，只要我在乎的这些人的身体健健康康的，其他无利于或者说没有伤害到身体健康的事情的话，都可以放下。是这样式儿的，我给你再举个例子，好不好？举一个不太恰当的例子啊，如果你的老公是那个伟神，就是那个北大的那个数学的那个天才，是那个伟神，你能寄希望于他能跟你说情话吗？你能寄希望于他能在乎你的情绪价值吗？你能寄希望于他能给你什么仪式感吗？不可能的。其实我有时候就把他当伪神看，我就说我就是上天派来照顾他的，对给自己想通了就完事儿了啊，就是有时候讲实话有点压抑，压抑的时候一定要自己找自己开心的人和事儿。我跟你讲啊，姐妹再见，爱人里面那个老师，黄执中老师对吧？黄执中老师讲过一段话，我一直记得，就是我们生命当中要多个情感支点，精神支点，有闺蜜，有朋友，各种各样的，包括龙飞，我某种程度上也成为了你们的一种情感上的支点。你多跟我们这样的人聊天呀，是不是就在生命当中不要去紧靠着这一个支点，说你老公对你感情好不好，爱不爱你这一个支点不要紧靠着这一个支点。是这样的，我也不是说期盼他爱。
我我是怕他经常这样子搞他的事情，然后就是看手机，我怕他自己心里不好，讲实话，我不祈求他有多爱我。我自己又有工作好单位又好，然后我又上班，然后群里还说我不把精力放在自闭症孩子身上。妈呀，我都已经90%都放在身上了，工作只留了5%了，你已经做得很好了。总体来说的话，虽然说我们很不幸孩子得了这样一个病状，但是坦率的说，幸好孩子是生在你这样的家庭，有你这样的经济条件，有你这样的爱他的妈妈，从这个角度来说的话，又是孩子的幸运。如果孩子生活在一个经济条件更差的，对他不负责任的家庭的话，可能夫妻两口子早就散了，可能这个孩子就没有人去爱他了，没有人去真正的去关心他了。我知道老公是家里顶梁柱，我就担心他自己的身体啊，因为他又不爱动，就经常钻研自己的。我担心他的身体啊，会出问题啊，或什么的就是当年不是因为关注农婚律师的话，当年自闭症的孩子我都差点要辞职了。现在目前这个状态，总体来说的话，你和丈夫的关系就是接纳，其实也挺好，在外人看来都很好。我们从来都不吵架，讲话也是很温柔细语。因为毕竟家里有特殊孩子嘛，不能让他看到爸爸妈妈有那个。
里面就就是他不主动的说话，所有的一切一定是你要对自己好。你怎么才叫对自己好呢？要解放自己的时间，解放自己的精力，去把你的一些琐碎的需要耗你的神，耗你的精力，耗你的体力的这些事儿给他cover掉，解决掉。一定要对自己好，你先好好的爱自己，因为精力的话，真的很大一部分都花在两个孩子身上了，好，今天咱俩就聊到这儿啊。好好，再见，拜拜，记得点赞关注哦。